we are lifted by lifting up the women
around us it's just a celebration of the
beauty of each other
hi we're the women of Hamilton and this
is first and last for Tyla the first
time I felt the power of this sisterhood
was in rehearsal for the workshop of
Hamilton we sat in chairs around a piano
learning music they put us in harmony
and we were all kindred spirits in that
we are lifted by lifting up the women
around us moving into our dressing room
downtown theater and the amount of
laughter would always shocked me when
any of us were sick or or not feeling
well and and feeling the power and the
strength and the support system that you
have from these sisters and rely on them
to carry you through the show the last
time I felt the power of the sisterhood
even when I'm not with these women or
with any of the women I consider my
sisters they are with me I I laugh at
myself in ways that I know they would
laugh at me I encouraged myself in ways
I know they would encourage me
sisterhood is is bigger than physical
proximity so it's always with me and it
does not end like five seconds ago when
Renee just gave her answer when I was at
a protest for black lives matter and I
heard a mother's of the victims and
their sisterhood and how they have band
together and have helped them through a
really really hard time the first
concert I went to was an Aretha Franklin
concert Prince the musicology tour
Michael Jackson that's friend the last
concert I went to was amazing small
ensemble in an Irish pub
went to Ireland last year basically a
showcase for my EP that just came out
called Bluebird in LA my own was in Ohio
with the symphony the first party that I
can remember that I went to you was my
third birthday party I have a tape of it
and me and my sister are dancing in the
living room - sounds of blackness my
birthday party
when I turned four years old many many
moons ago my cousins
I believe eleventh or twelfth birthday
party and we went to go see the first
Harry Potter movie the last party that I
can remember before quarantine my
closing night party for cyrano that i
was in off broadway with the new group
the last party I remember was my son's
birthday party it was the first social
distance event that we had a few friends
drove over and they played a game of
charades my friend Anna woods daughter's
second birthday party